we've so far described abstractly what
we mean by a dot product by a definition
of a B equals the magnitude of a times
cosine theta times the magnitude of B
but many times in physics problems we
actually have vectors in space and we
want to see how to do this in terms of a
Cartesian or any coordinate system in
particular so let's set up a coordinate
system we will call it Cartesian a and J
and now this is very important let's
define a vector a here and let's have
another vector in a completely different
point B we're still can take the dot
product of these two vectors but in
order this is our plus X plus y and I'm
only doing things in two dimensions so
how do we calculate the dot product well
the first thing that we want to look at
is our unit vectors what are the dot
products of unit vectors well if we take
I hat dot I hat that's the magnitude of
I hat times cosine of the angle 0 times
the magnitude of I hat and cosine of 0
is 1 and the magnitude of unit vectors
are 1 so when you dot product the unit
vector with itself you get 1 and
therefore it's also true for the J hat J
hat J hat is 1 what happens when you dot
product two vectors that are
perpendicular well in this case this is
0 because the angle theta is 90 degrees
and remember that cosine of 90 degrees
is 0 and anyway
when two vectors are perpendicular
there's no component of one vector
that's parallel to the other so these
are the essential facts that we're going
to need to calculate the dot product of
two vectors that are separated in space
so the way we do that is we'll begin by
drawing writing down the vectors in
Cartesian coordinates where ax is a
scalar and the vector part is in the
unit vector and we have a Y J hat and
likewise we can write B as B X I hat
plus B Y J hat and now when we take the
dot product
of these two vectors that's we're gonna
write out all the terms here so that you
see them so here is our scalar or dot
product we use those words
interchangeably now notice that we've
already shown that the dot product
distributes over vector addition and
also if you multiply a scalar by a
vector you can pull the scalar out so
there's four terms here ax I hat dot BX
I huh plus ax I huh
dot B Y jaehun plus ay Y J hat dot BX I
had this is a little tedious to write
out B Y J huh and now because these are
scalars we can pull them out and the
only part of a dot product that matters
is how the unit vectors dot and that's
why we have these two results I had that
I had as one J Hutta
J hat is one and I hat J hat is zero so
the first term is ax BX I hat J hat is
zero so we don't need that J huh dot I
hat is zero and finally J hat J hat is
one and so we get plus ay Y B Y and
that's how we define the dot product in
Cartesian coordinates of two vectors now
notice that if we dotted a vector a dot
with itself that would just be ax ax
plus ay Y a Y which is the components
squared and that's equal to the
magnitude of the vector squared and so
we can say that the magnitude of the
vector of any vector is you take its dot
product with itself you take the square
root but remember we always take the
positive square root because magnitudes
are positive and that's how we calculate
the scalar product for vectors
many times in the application of physics
when we have physical quantities that
are vectors in different places we use
vector decomposition and we use this
procedure we'll learn how to do this in
cup this is the Cartesian picture we'll
learn how to do that in polar
coordinates when we need it later on